chris flexon coming off a career
performance on that road trip at fenway
park a career best in both innings
pitched
and in strikeouts he was phenomenal
against a really good lineup volunteer
strikes the count to fletcher
as he whacks a pitch way out of the
strike zone into right field
lead off single for fletcher and that'll
bring up designated hitter shohei ohtani
swinging a fly ball into shallow left
center field over his hagerty sam is
there
and will make the catch and there's one
away and so one on
and one away and here is center fielder
mike trout
there's a purple that's lined into left
field and trout is on at first base
so two on for the angels here in the top
of the first no score
and the banner will be third baseman
anthony rondon who's yet to really get
things going this year
brendon takes a breaking ball to the
left well hit
had to be back and he can't make the
catch fletcher scores easily
angels strike first in seattle tonight
now the angels have runners on it second
and third with one out and the battery
is right fielder jared walsh and walsh
sends that into the opposite field
hagerty's got this one trout tags up at
four throw home is not in time
two nothing angels brendon on second out
with two outs and two runs are in two
nothing angels here's justin upton
swing and a fly ball into shallow right
center field going out
more calling for it moore still calling
for it and dylan gets back in time to
make the catch
and then will retire the side 29 year
old southpaw and ruhini on the mound for
the angels tonight
coming off a really good one friday in
houston that unfortunately did not net
him a positive decision
bleeded it off [ __ ] hannigan this team
just hasn't hit an al
worst 207 batting average at the start
of play tonight swinging a fly ball deep
into center field
goodbye baseball welcome back mitch
haniger
a couple of days off he goes straight
away center field
and it's now the angels two and the
mariners won
how about that and the batter now is ty
france who's playing first base for them
oh and they say he swung the bat on the
appeal down to the first base umpire tim
timmons wow
a strikeout for hiney one out for the
mariners here in the bottom of the first
and the bender will be third base with
kyle c fastball up and away that's
sent to the opposite field for upton and
now number two
here's kyle lewis swung on line drive
left field up and coming in can't get to
it a base hit
so the mariners have the time run aboard
with two outs two one angels and that'll
bring up catcher luis terence
one two pitch popped up fletcher's got
it at the cut out
and that is how the inning will end
second baseman dylan moore will
lay things off the wind up in the 3-2
pitch swung on well hit ball
deep into the gap in left center field
opt-in going back
looking up and goodbye baseball
underneath the out-of-town scoreboard
dylan moore has just tied it up at two
to two here in the bottom of any number
two
here's one of the bangers on this team
shohei oh tony
all right let's see if if flexson stays
soft away to ohtani the way he did in
the
first oh show he got that one he got
that one haniger measures it off but
it's not coming back
number eight for ohtani angels get their
first homer tonight and move back on top
it's now
3-2 there's dylan moore see if he can
make something happen with two outs
breaks his back this will drop in for a
base hit
time france peddling around here's a
throw home he slides he's safe
and we are tied at three and now the
angels have one eye with one away here
in the top of the fourth inning
here's albert pools this is pounded out
to
left field hagerty hagerty makes
the catch 6 68
we'll have to wait sam hagerty racing
back
into the gap in left center field timing
a leap on the run
and rouhini's going to give it another
in at least back out there for the
fourth
tom murphy will be the next batter
gloved out towards right center rising
going back
deep and gone tom murphy
the mariners third homer tonight off of
heaty and
murphy put the mariners in front four to
three so we're under at second to start
the inning now after the walking wild
pitch
and a chance for hagerty to play to run
with a base hit
dylan taking off to third
dylan's coming home the sprint is on and
he scores standing
five three mariners runner on its second
here is jp crawford
the 1-1 to jp swinging a fly ball down
the right field line that's going to
drop in a fair ball into the corner
he's got plenty of speed for this and
the mariners pick up a run here in the
bottom of the eighth here is tom murphy
to the gap in right center field drops
in base hit
crawford is wheeling around third and
scores
tom murphy into second it's a 7-3
mariners lead they're added on to the
8th inning
zieger with a walk and the mariners have
the bases loaded
for kyle lewis two balls and two strikes
the count of lewis
popped him up and this one will stay in
play
and there are two away now brings up
catcher luis terrence so ben rowan
trying to keep this game
right here that pitch there is a called
third strike and
boy rowan got the benefit of the doubt
on that one
torrens is out looking and that's how
the
inning will end here's the good news
rafael monteiro
the seattle closer has really been their
only inconsistent reliever this year
more good news they've got the heart of
the lineup here in the night sharply
hitting a fair ball into the left field
corner
trout's on his way into second with a
second knock of the ball game
and now rendon with an rbi opportunity
he cashed in with a stake back in the
first
right to france calls off montero
meanwhile trout scampers into third one
out
here is right fielder jared walsh
walsh sends one out to shallow center
field of base hit that's going to drive
in trout make it a three-run game
this is the first hit for wallace versus
seattle
saw them off tricky in between crawford
slings to second on to first
not in time two outs upton at first
facing pujols 1-1 pitch
soft chopper crawford charging he's got
plenty of time
ball game over mariners win they take
the first of three against the angels
7-4
our final score well it's great to see
the bottom of the lineup brit flex and
struggling a little bit the bottom of
the line of take care of business dylan
moore with a home run today
stolen base scored a couple of runs it's
impressive across the board murphy also
chipping in with another home run
but the mariners overall nice way to get
this home stand started
a lot of good stuff with this one
mariners win it 7-4